all right kendall wearing a mask may
have another benefit this season
protection against allergens here in
southern nevada i spoke with one of the
southwest medical doctors to learn more
about seasonal allergies check it out
we need you especially now because as
you just told me we just got rid of some
rain and tomorrow
mulberry starts and everybody should
just get their tissue and their allergy
medicine right
yeah historically mulberry starts around
the 15th of march
we went 200 some days without rain
you've got a nice little soaker so i
expect the mulberry
trees to pollinate and that's one of our
high pollinators
and then it's usually followed by olive
in about
april 15th well so since we're on the
topic of our
our southern nevada pollinators you know
what are some of the allergens that we
that we see here
well we just went through ash season
um we're down we're now in mulberry
pine is about ready to pollinate and
then
olive will pollinate and then we'll get
privet
and then bermuda grass is our major
grass here
and that pretty much pollinates any time
it's above 55
degrees but below 102.
okay okay and what are some of the
symptoms that these allergens can cause
us
well it's usually itchy eyes stuffy nose
post basal drips sneezing
some people did air congestion some
people just get
you know a hoarse voice or a cough how
do we control these allergy symptoms
during this time
well good luck on controlling them
because
someone else is in control of that what
we can do is react to them
number one take a proactive approach the
highest pollen counts are
usually in the mornings so if you're a
morning exerciser
consider moving that to the evening once
you come in
shower off change your clothes change
your filters
um and actually wearing a mask
is actually very beneficial it will
filter out a lot of stuff
there's most of the medicines have gone
over the counter
and it is safe to up the dose of
antihistamines
and you can go above the recommended
dose
it's safe to go four times the dose
okay so you recommend i at least throw
an allergy pill in my in my daily
routine
yeah as long as it's by the second
generation which would be claritin
zyrtec or allegra not the brand names
are they generic okay okay good advice
and
what are some of the most common
treatments or treatment options for for
allergens here
well the most common treatment option is
going to be nasal steroids and
antihistamines
if people don't re respond to that and
we add nasal washes to that
then we'll do traditional allergy shots
where we actually
um inject you with your allergic tube
and that's a six to nine month process
that works you go about
three three to five years
and you're going to get 10 years worth
of benefit for people with sinusitis and
asthma
it tends to shut that off oh wow so when
these steps aren't enough and you have
to go a little
above and beyond it's just time to time
to see a doctor about it right
to see a doctor yes it might be time for
me to see him as well optim care lung
and allergy care has locations across
southern nevada
you can call them at 702-724-8844